[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE STRYKER: It's great
to be here at Google.
Just getting a
quick sound, here.
[MUSIC - DAVE STRYKER, "BLUE
STRUT"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.
How about it for great Jared
Gold on the Hammond B3 organ.
The great Mark Whitfield
Jr. on the drums.
My name's Dave Stryker.
Thank you so much.
So with the organ
trio, we always
have to start out
with the blues.
So that was called "Blue
Strut," one of my tunes,
and we're going
to continue, now,
from a record I did
called "Eight Track--"
something by the
great Curtis Mayfield.
And this is a lovely,
sensitive love ballad he
calls "Pusherman," "Super Fly."
1, 2--
[MUSIC - DAVE STRYKER,
"PUSHERMAN"]
[APPLAUSE]
How about it for Mark
Whitfield Jr. on the drums,
Jared Gold on the organ?
[JAZZ MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
That was, of course, by
one of the fantastic jazz
groups of all time, Bread.
I know none of you know
who I'm talking about.
It was a group from the '70s.
They weren't jazz.
But this record I did
called "Eight Track--"
how many of you have heard
of what an eight track is?
I know this is going back.
All right, well, I
did a couple records
called "Eight Track"
and "Eight Track II,"
and did tunes that I grew
up with from the '70s,
but put our jazz slant on it.
So that came from that.
And there was a lot of
great tunes from that era,
so it's fun.
And a lot of people
know those tunes,
so it's a cool way to
connect with people.
RICHARD BIELAK: I like
to hear origin stories.
How did you get
started playing jazz?
DAVE STRYKER: Well,
when I was coming up,
it was about The Beatles.
I had an older sister
who was into The Beatles,
and so it's just really cool
to watch them on "Ed Sullivan
Show" and stuff.
And I said, I want
to be like that.
I want to be cool.
So it's all about being cool
when you're a kid, right?
And started taking guitar
lessons when I was about 10,
and playing in bands
and stuff, and playing
all the tunes that were on
the radio, and rock stuff.
And went to a jam session.
Got better, went to a jam
session at The Union one time.
And they were playing some
jazz, and so I got up there
and sat in.
And I had long hair,
Fender Telecaster,
and I just got up there and
started ripping my rock licks.
And one of the guys came
up and said, hey, man.
This is jazz.
You can't be playing that rock.
So I was like, uh-oh.
You mean I'm not amazing?
[LAUGHTER]
So the next day, I
went to Homer's Records
in Omaha, Nebraska--
where I'm from.
Said, where's the jazz records?
And he said, back there.
So I went back and ended up
walking out, believe it or not,
with a John Coltrane record
called "My Favorite Things,"
and a George Benson
record called
"Beyond the Blue Horizon."
And I don't know
how that worked,
but those are still two
of my favorite records.
And just started
listening to it,
just like I had been
listening to the rock stuff.
And I was like, wow, I've no
idea what's going on here.
So it was intriguing.
And me and my friends just
started learning tunes.
And back then, we were
working six nights a week
at The Hilton, playing--
the first two sets would
be playing jazz tunes--
"Satin Doll" and
"Girl From Ipanema"--
while people danced or ate.
And then the last two sets
would be top 40 of the day.
So just got into it that way,
then just kept practicing
and moved out to LA
for a couple years.
And we started sitting in
with some people out there.
And then moved to New York about
1980, and went up to Harlem
and sat in with a guy
named Brother Jack McDuff.
And he gave me a gig, and he was
one of the greats of the organ.
And he had previously had Grant
Green in his group, George
Benson, and Pat Martino.
RICHARD BIELAK: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVE STRYKER: Yeah, so
when I joined the band,
he finally got a good
guitar player, so it was--
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, so that was--
then after that, I met the
great Stanley Turrentine,
and he asked me
to join him, and I
was with Stanley Turrentine,
the great tenor player,
for over 10 years.
And all at the same time,
I'm in New York playing
with all the people here.
And just keep practicing.
That's the great thing
we love about jazz,
is the improvisation
aspect of it.
Whereas we're playing melodies
at the beginning and the end
of the song, but
in the middle, it's
wide open and we're playing
over the structure of the song--
the harmonic structure.
But anything can happen.
It's really exciting.
RICHARD BIELAK: It's
different every time.
DAVE STRYKER: Yes.
RICHARD BIELAK: So you write
lots of your own tunes.
How do you do that?
Do you just wake up one morning
and decide to write a tune,
or you have a process?
Or just you play something
sometimes, and it sounds good?
DAVE STRYKER: Yeah,
a lot of times tunes
would come out of an interesting
harmonic structure or core
changes that I thought would
be cool to play on-- that I
thought I could play over well.
So I would write a
tune around that.
A lot of times, you'll
come up with a melody,
and then you just
want to flesh it out.
So there's a whole
lot of different ways.
A lot of times--
I work well under pressure.
So if I have a record
date or something,
I'll realize, oh, man.
I got to write some music.
So having that coming
record date or gig, whatever
I have coming up that I
need to learn music for,
that will inspire me
to write music, too.
But I have written
a lot of music,
and I find that that part
of my musical personality,
as well as my playing,
all goes together.
RICHARD BIELAK: So you did
this record a couple of years
ago with a bunch of horns.
That was "Routes."
And did you do all the
horn parts as well?
DAVE STRYKER: On
that record, that
was actually by my
partner, Steve Slagle,
that we had we have a group.
And we did a record
called "Routes."
And he did most of
the arranging on that.
And I wrote some of the tunes.
But he did the horn arranging.
But I've also done horn
projects with four horns called
"Blue to the Bone," where I
did a lot of the arranging,
or I worked with
the other people,
like Bob Parsons as arranger to
write you know the horn parts.
So it keeps it interesting
to do a whole lot
of different things.
I guess I've been putting
about one record out a year
since about 1988
was my first record.
And I was with a European
label for many years called
SteepleChase.
And I could count on at
least one record a year.
So it's always cool to
have a goal or something
to look forward to to inspire
you to try to write some music
or think of a new project.
So I've done all kinds
of records, everything
from just a trio, to big band.
RICHARD BIELAK: So one other
thing I wanted to talk to you
about is teaching.
So you teach a lot of, I
guess, college students.
How do you find
this new generation?
DAVE STRYKER: They're terrible.
No.
RICHARD BIELAK: I thought so.
[LAUGHS]
DAVE STRYKER: Just kidding.
I enjoy it a lot.
I teach.
When I came up--
don't tell anybody.
But I actually came
from the school
of just playing on the road.
You know?
And I didn't go to college.
Not that-- I just was gigging.
Like I said, I was working.
I was just always working.
And my folks were
supportive of that.
You know?
They saw that I was
doing something I loved.
And so I learned
the music like I
think most people have learned
it that are the greats,
and that is from listening
to the who came before.
It's an oral tradition.
This is jazz.
Everybody from Louis
Armstrong, maybe one
of the first jazz guys.
He used to listen
to King Oliver.
Dizzy Gillespie and
Miles listened to Louis.
But everybody kind of puts
their own thing on it.
Charlie Christian was one of
the first jazz guitar players.
And he influenced Wes
Montgomery and George Benson,
who influenced guys
of my generation,
like Pat Metheny
and John Scofield.
And so it's just a continuing
evolution of the music.
But that's how I learned how
to play is listening to records
and taking ideas off the record.
We call it transcribing,
which you would actually
note for note take off like Wes
Montgomery or George Benson,
Pat Martino, Miles, Coltrane
solo off the record,
figure out how they're playing
over these chord changes.
And hopefully, some of that
rubs off on your own playing.
And so when I teach, I try to
use those ideas that I used
and try to help them
figure out their own voice.
You know?
So it's very gratifying to do.
And I didn't expect
to be doing it.
And it's just part of what I do.
I mean, I'm very busy
playing, and touring around,
and recording, and producing.
And I have a record label now,
and doing all kinds of stuff.
But I enjoy it.
Going out to Indiana is nice.
I go out every other
week and teach out there.
RICHARD BIELAK: So you started
this new thing, speaking
of technology, with ArtistShare,
where you have online lessons.
DAVE STRYKER: Yeah, that just--
RICHARD BIELAK: So how
is that experience?
DAVE STRYKER: That's great.
I mean, I just started this.
And this whole internet
thing, I really
think it's going to catch on.
I feel like I'm really
on the ground floor here.
No.
RICHARD BIELAK: The 11th floor.
DAVE STRYKER: 11th floor?
OK.
Yeah, so I just launched my own
jazz guitar teaching website
at ArtistWorks.com.
And it's an amazing
company out in Napa Valley.
And they have what's called
video exchange technology.
And David Butler is
the guy who started it.
And he was originally
one of the guys at AOL.
And he's a really great
guy and a really smart guy.
And he started this website.
And they do everything from
Bluegrass and rock and roll
to classical and jazz.
So I'm kind of the
jazz guitar guy there.
And how it works is it's
a subscription site.
But I've put up about maybe
120 lessons, everything
from basic, intermediate,
up to advanced.
And the lessons are,
say, 10 minutes long.
And I cover a subject.
And then the student
can send in a video
of them playing of what I was
just working on with them.
And then about once a week,
I answer the video exchanges
by sending them a video.
So it's not in real
time, but you're still
getting one-on-one with me.
And it's kind of cool.
You signed up, you told me.
RICHARD BIELAK: Yes, yes, I did.
It's very cool.
DAVE STRYKER: I expect
to get you on there
very soon with a video for me.
In case you don't
know, Richie is
a fine jazz guitarist himself.
That's how we know each other.
He's studied with me.
RICHARD BIELAK: Thank you.
DAVE STRYKER: And yeah,
so it's really cool.
And you don't have to
send in video exchange.
If you subscribe, you can
watch other people's things.
So it's kind of a cool thing.
And it's brand new for me.
So check it out at
ArtistWorks.com.
RICHARD BIELAK: So does anybody
have any questions, or should
I--
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First, thanks for coming.
DAVE STRYKER: Sure.
AUDIENCE: It's fantastic.
I was wondering if you could
speak a little bit to the state
of jazz in general.
Obviously, you mentioned
spending a lot of time
out on the road, dabbling
in new technology.
But when you look at the
mainstream situation, I mean,
even rock and roll is
struggling right now.
And jazz has been out of
the spotlight for a while.
I'm just wondering if
you, as an insider,
could speak to what you found
out in the world and the scene.
What's the world of jazz like?
Is it healthy right now?
Is there a lot of
good stuff out there
that you've found versus
kind of getting buried
by the avalanche of pop music?
DAVE STRYKER: Great question.
Jazz is very healthy
and alive, especially
where we are right here.
There's so many exciting
things happening
and people trying new things.
There's other fads of
music that come and go
and groups come and go.
People have a hit.
You don't hear
about them anymore.
Jazz is always going to be here.
To me, it's real music.
It's America's art form.
It's something we've brought.
It comes from the blues.
And it's not going anywhere.
You know?
You're not going to make
millions of dollars at it.
But nobody does it for that.
They do it because
they love to play.
They love this
interaction you do.
There's nothing like this.
Those solos we just
played just now,
they might not have been
our best we ever did.
But they were the only one
that happened at this moment.
And it was because
of the communication
between the three of us.
And just that interaction
is a beautiful thing.
And that's one of the
things that jazz has--
the blues and the influence,
and then the harmonic things
that have been brought to
us from all the greats,
from Louis Armstrong up to
Charlie Parker, and now,
Herbie Hancock, all
these great players.
There's so many young
players out on the scene
right now doing exciting things.
So the audience for
jazz is growing too
with different
influences coming in,
with people like Robert
Glasper and different people
incorporating hip-hop
and different rhythms,
bringing in different audiences.
So in that way,
it's also growing.
But as far as just straight
ahead jazz, I mean,
it'll never go
anywhere because it's--
the people that love it just
want to hear some swing,
head down to the
Village Vanguard,
or any of these clubs in town,
the Jazz Standard, Birdland.
There's a whole bunch of club.
Smalls has a lot of
great stuff happening.
So yeah, especially
in New York, there's
some amazing things happening.
Thanks for that question though.
RICHARD BIELAK: Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was kind of trying
to watch your right hand.
I was trying to figure
out what it was doing.
It looks like you have
sort of a hybrid technique.
You've got pick.
You've got fingernails.
You've got-- what's
going on there?
DAVE STRYKER: I really
can't answer that question.
I'm sorry, man.
It's just a secret, top secret.
People ask that.
Like right now, my
pick is right there.
And so when I play, if I want
to play like a single note line,
my pick--
[DEMONSTRATES PASSAGE]
That's with the pick.
Now, if I want to switch--
[DEMONSTRATES PASSAGE]
--then the pick
just goes in there.
I just hold it there.
And I can use my fingers
individually to comp.
We call it comping when you're
playing chords or whatever.
[DEMONSTRATES PASSAGE]
So then I switch to
the pick right there.
So you've got to be able to--
to me, I just did it naturally.
I don't know.
Some people though--
I think you could also
do like Eddie Van Halen,
and get a mic stand,
and put 500 pics on there.
You know?
That works too.
Or you can set it on your leg,
and then it falls on the floor.
And you can stop and
pick it up, you know.
There's a lot of
different techniques.
Some people put
it in their mouth.
This I don't recommend because
it interrupts the gig when
you have to go to
the emergency room
because you just
swallowed your pick.
But yeah, that's all.
That's the answer.
I just keep it right there.
And then I still can
use this finger to--
[PLUCKS STRING] play with so
I have my five fingers here.
RICHARD BIELAK: OK, so
how about some more music?
[APPLAUSE]
DAVE STRYKER: Yeah, you
want to hear one more?
All right.
So let's bring up Jared Gold
on the Hammond B-3 organ
and a Mark Whitfield, Jr.
[APPLAUSE]
We could do a whole talk on
this instrument right here.
With the advent of
digital technology
and digital keyboards, you're
never going to see one of those
too often.
This has got tone
wheels in it and tubes.
It's called a Hammond B-3 organ.
And that's called a Leslie.
It's a rotating speaker.
But it's a classic sound.
And like we talked about, Jack
McDuff that I got to play with,
he was one of the greats of it.
Jimmy Smith is another one.
So a lot of times, you'll just
see a little digital keyboard
that simulates
the sound of that.
But this thing, you
actually feel it.
Right?
Yeah, it's cool.
All right, so we'll do something
off my new record, Strykin'
Ahead.
This is a tune I wrote
called "Shadowboxing."
Thanks for coming out
and hanging out with us.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - DAVE STRYKER,
"SHADOWBOXING"]
[ORGAN SOLO]
[DRUM SOLO]
[APPLAUSE]
[GUITAR SOLO]
DAVE STRYKER: Thanks a lot.
All right, Mark Whitfield,
Jr. on the drums.
Jared Gold on the
Hammond B-3 organ.
Dave Stryker on guitar.
Thank you very much, Google.
It was great being here.
[APPLAUSE]